the race against time after a cyber
attack on a major source of fuel for the
east coast
colonial pipeline halted operations on
thousands of miles of pipeline on friday
after hackers forced a shutdown by
taking the company's data hostage yikes
that's nearly half of the fuel consumed
on the east coast
senior investigative correspondent
that's catherine herrick is following
this story
catherine good morning to you a few more
days of this and gas prices could rise
that's not good as people are starting
to creep out of their homes and get in
their cars and go places so what do we
know
right now gail this was a ransomware
attack meaning cyber criminals
likely encrypted the data and then
demanded money to unlock it
colonial pipeline has not said whether a
ransom was paid
the fbi and a private cyber security
firm are working closely with the
company
to determine how the networks were
compromised
the cyber attack shuttered more than 5
000 miles of a pipeline that carries
about 45 percent of fuel consumed on the
east coast
after hackers breached georgia-based
colonial pipeline's computer system
ransomware is a national security threat
chris krebs the former director of
homeland security's
cyber infrastructure security agency
says a
criminal gang with links to moscow is a
leading suspect
who or what was behind this attack on
colonial
there is a ransomware crew known as
darkseid they use kind of a double tap
technique of both locking up the
networks and demanding
demanding ransom but as well as
exfiltrating or taking
sensitive data out of the the company
colonial runs pipelines from houston
texas to linden new jersey
transporting more than 100 million
gallons of gasoline
diesel jet fuel and home heating oil
every day
the company said sunday some smaller
lateral lines are now restored
but not the main lines it also said it's
taken
additional precautionary measures to
monitor and protect its pipeline
of course the the next few days that
that could
start getting um you know you could see
local stocks
start running a little bit lower
ransomware attacks are a growing problem
for the u.s
the homeland security secretary recently
confirmed
more than 350 million dollars in ransom
was paid last year
with small businesses especially hard
hit and the number of ransomware attacks
spiked in 2020 by about 300 percent
is enough being done to prevent these
attacks
i don't think we've done enough of is
signal very clearly
with our partners in europe and
elsewhere
to the nations like russia that
harbor these criminals and tell them
that this this will not stand any longer
over the weekend the commerce secretary
told cbs news that's an all hands on
deck situation
current and former government officials
say ransomware criminals are ramping up
attacks
on critical infrastructure including
hospitals and schools
that could cause harm to americans
anthony
catherine thank you did not realize we
paid 350 million dollars in ransom last
year